Queridos amigos, amigas, prestad mucha atención
porque lo que aquí os vamos a contar no os
va a dejar indiferentes.
Y para empezar quedaros con este dato:
Dos terceras partes de todos los habitantes
del planeta tierran viven en países donde
la tasa de fertilidad no alcanza nisiquiera
la tasa de reemplazo, esto es, 2,1 nacimientos
por mujer en edad fertil, que se considera
es la tasa que permite mantener una población
estable en el largo plazo.
En el mundo desarrollado tan solo Israel ha
logrado situarse constantemente por encima
de esta cifra.
Y evidentemente esto es algo que tiene consecuencias,
fijaos:
N1("El crecimiento de la población mundial
alcanza la tasa más baja desde 1950".
FT)
De hecho, el aumento de la mortalidad, la
caída en el número de nacimientos y una
menor inmigración neta por culpa de la pandemia
hizo que durante 2020 y 2021 la población
europea se redujera en más de 2 millones
de personas.
(Este es un proceso al que nos podemos ir
aconstumbrando porque será recurrente a lo
largo del presente siglo…
En Europa, y también en otros muchos países:
la población de Japón se ha estado reduciendo
desde el año 2010, la de Corea del Sur comenzó
a contraerse en 2020 y se espera que la población
china haga lo propio como muy tarde este mismo
año o el siguiente.
Y hay expertos que incluso apuntan que este
declive ya ha comenzado.
De hecho se espera que para mediados de siglo,
la población china se reduzca en 12 millones
de personas por año.)
¿Qué queréis que os diga?
Buena parte del mudno cada vez tiene menos
jóvenes y muchas más personas mayores.
Ahora bien, esperad un momento….
Porque esta no es toda la historia.
No somos concscientes de ello en el día a
día, pero África, el continente simpre olvidado,
está experimentando lo que algunos consideran
como el mayor despegue demográfico de toda
la historia de la humanidad.
Un crecimiento que lejos de ralentizarse se
ha disparado durante las últimas décadas
y que promete marcar un antes y un después
en la mismísima historia de la humanidad.
(“Este es el siglo de África”.
Cyril Ramaphosa, presidente de Sudáfrica)
Y, ojo, que esto no ha hecho más que empezar.
El cambio que os vamos a contar va mucho más
allá de lo que seguro, seguro, nunca os habéis
planetado.
Arranquemos.
[Pero, antes dejadme que os cuente una cosa
que creo os va a interesar.
Se habla mucho de crisis y la palabra recesión
está por todas partes.
Ahora bien, ¿Podemos detectar una crisis
financiera o económica antes de que esta
ocurra?
¿Existe algún tipo de “guía” que podamos
seguir para saber cuándo estamos cerca de
experimentar un nuevo cataclismo financiero?
Pues lo cierto es que en cierta forma sí
que existe.
Tras la gran crisis financiera del 2008, dos
economistas de la Universidad de Berkeley
desarrollaron un mçetodo para poder diagnosticar
crisis financieras.
Un método al alcance de todos.
¿Quieres saber más sobre esta cuestión?
¿Quieres saber cómo podemos diagnosticar
una crisis financiera antes de que ocurra?
Pues no te pierdas el último vídeo de Si
lo Hubbiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto continuemos.
(CÓMO AFRICA CAMBIARÁ EL MUNDO)
En 2018 el presidente Museveni de Uganda abrió
su discurso sobre el estado del país, presumiendo
de que la población de Uganda había saltado
de unos 14 millones de personas en 1986 a
más de 40 millones.
El crecimiento demográfico anual que había
sido de un 2,5% de media en los 20 años anteriores
a su larguísimo reinado como presidente había
superado el 3,5%.
Esto ha hecho que Uganda tenga una de las
poblaciones más jóvenes de todo el mundo.
Su edad media es de apenas 17 años.
Y para que os hagais una idea tres cuartas
partes de los ugandeses tienen menos de 30
años.
Una enorme cantera….
Preparada para tener muchos, muchísimos hijos.
Porque, amigos, amigas, hablamos de un país
dónde las mujeres tienen de media 5 hijos.
Esto es así, entre otras cosas, porque la
población es muy joven y además empiezan
a tener hijos muy pronto.
Algo que por cierto no ha cambiado a pesar
de que las tasas de mortalidad infantil se
han desplomado.
¿El resultado?
La población de Uganda está creciendo a
un ritmo de casi el 40% por década.
En otro discurso televisado, el propio presidento
Museveni fue muy claro:
(“África ha estado sufriendo de subpoblación….
Ahora lo estamos solucionando”.
Yoweri Museveni, Presidente de Uganda)
Y es que, veréis, a pesar de ser el segundo
continente más grande del mundo, África
sólo ha sido responsable de una quinta parte
del crecimiento demográfico mundial desde
1950.
Pero ahora eso está cambiando…
Por completo.
La cultura, la religión, incluso la política
todo, absolutamente todo es pronatalista en
África.
Y amigos, amigas, se han puesto las pilas.
Y vaya si lo han hecho.
Una vez que te das cuenta de su escala…
Bueno, digamos, que es probable que te estalle
la cabeza.
El mundo que conoces va a cambiar por completo
durante las próximas décadas.
Fijaos.
(En 1914 se estima que la población de África
era de apenas 124 millones de personas.
Hoy son ya 1.340 millones de africanos.
Mientras la población de Asia se multiplicó
entre 3 y 4 veces, la población africana
se multiplicó por 11.
Y eso son palabras mayores.
Por ejemplo, durante la revolución industrial
la población de Europa apenas se duplicó.
Hablamos, por tanto, de un crecimiento inédito
en toda la historia de la humanidad.
Pero eso, eso ha sido tan sólo el comienzo.
Las estimaciones de Naciones Unidas apuntan
a que para el año 2050 la población de África
superará los 2.400 millones de personas…
Es decir, si en 1980 1 de cada 10 personas
del mundo eran africanas, a mediados de este
mismo siglo, en apenas unos pocos años, aproximadamente
1 de cada 4 personas en la tierra será de
este continente.)
Para que os hagais una idea de lo que esto
supone 2.500 millones de personas equivale
a toda la población que tenía el mundo en
1950.
Apenas 100 años más tarde esa será tan
solo la población de África.
Ahora mismo este continente es ya, con mucha
diferencia, el principal motor del crecimiento
demográfico del mundo.
Por ejemplo, actualmente sólo 8 países tienen
un crecimiento demográfico superior al 3%,
lo que implica que la población se duplique
cada 20-24 años.
Todos están en África.
Actualmente sólo 11 países tienen una tasa
de fertilidad de cinco o más hijos.
Todos están en África.
De los 20 países de todo el mundo cuya población
crecerá más para el año 2050, 12 están,
precisamente, en esta región del mundo.
En otras palabras: Acostumbrate, pero el mundo
que conocer dependerá cada vez más y más
de esta tierra.
Y eso no es todo.
Lo más increible es que todo apunta q eue
la población africana seguirá creciendo.
Será la única con tasas de crecimiento relevantes
de todo el planeta tierra.
En 2050 aproximadamente el 40% de todos los
nacimientos tendrán lugar…
¿Sabéis dónde?
Exacto.
En 2050 38 de los 40 países con la edad media
más reducida del mundo estarán….
Ya sabéis donde.
Así que para finales de siglo, pues, muchos
expertos, incluyendo Naciones Unidas, apuntan
que la población de África supondrá cerca
del 40% de toda la población mundial.
Y, ojo, porque si se cumple este pronóstico
eso querría decir que África será responsable
de más del 90% del crecimiento de la población
mundial entre 2020 y 2100.
¿Os imaginais un mundo dónde la mitad de
todos los jóvenes o casi la mitad de toda
la fuerza laboral sea precisamente africana?
Evidentemente eso cambiaría por completo
la realidad global.
Este continente se convertiría en algo así
como el motor del planeta.
Una sociedad joven y pujante frente a las
envejecidas sociedades de los hoy países
desarrollados.
Lo cambiaría todo.
Evidentemente, hablar del año 2100 no es
como hablar del 2050.
A un plazo tan largo las previsiones pueden
no cumplirse…
Pero si algo parece claro es que como poco
1 de cada 3 personas de todo el mundo será
de este continente.
(Fijaos por ejemplo en el caso de Niger - uno
de los países más pobres del mundo y uno
de los aliados, por cierto, de Occidente en
la lucha contra la infiltración yihadista
en el Sahel.
En este país las mujeres tienen una media
de más de 7 hijos, la cual por cierto se
ha incrementado en los últimos años.
Eso explica que la edad media del país sea
de apenas 15 años.
Vamos que practicamente hablamos de un macrocolegio.
En apenas 100 años, entre 1950 y 2050 este
país habrá visto multiplicarse su población
por 25.
De 2,5 millones a más de 60 millones de habitantes)
Ahora bien, la primera pregunta que se nos
puede venir a la cabeza es…
Pero, ¿realmente coge tanta gente en África?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
A pesar de que su población se ha multiplicado
por 6 desde 1950, África sigue siendo esencialmente
un continente vacio.
Su densidad de población es de unas 44 personas
por km2, menos de un tercio que la de China.
Y, por ejemplo, si excluimos a los pequeños
estados insulares, sólo 5 países, Ruanda,
Burundi, Uganda, Nigeria y Malawi, tienen
densidades :de población cercanas o superiores
a las 200 personas por km2.
Corea del Sur, por ejemplo, supera las 500
y Bangladesh las 1.200.
Así que margen, lo que se dice margen, pues
hay de sobra.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente son fiables estas
previsiones?
¿Es que en este continente no está teniendo
lugar lo que se conoce como transición demográfica?
¿O es que los expertos no lo han tenido en
cuenta?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas.
¿Qué supondrá exactamente todo este brutal
crecimiento, esta brutal revolución demográfica
para el resto?
Pues bien, veamoslo.
(LA ANOMALÍA DEL CONTINENTE OLVIDADO)
Europa, América Latina, Asia…
Cada vez que una sociedad se ha modernizado
y se ha desarrollado económicamente ha tenido
lugar lo que conocemos cómo transición demográfica:
En un primer momento la tasa de mortalidad
disminuye, el crecimiento de la población
se acelera, pero de repnte la fertilidad se
desploma y el crecimiento demográfico se
ralentiza, hasta que practicamente se frena
del todo, he incluso, comienza a ser negativo
por el creciente envejecimiento de la población.
Pues bien, en África las cosas parecen completamente
distintas.
Aunque la tasa de mortalidad se ha desplomado
con fuerza y la esperanza de vida de la población
ha crecido mucho, en África la reducción
de las tasas de fecundidad están descenciendo
a un ritmo anormalmente reducido.
En el África Subsahariana apenas ha pasado
de 6,5 nacimientos por mujer a 5,4 en los
últimos 20 años.
Eh, incluso, en algunos países este ha vuelto
a crecer.
De locos.
(“En algunos países [de África], la fecundidad
aún no ha empezado a descender y puede que
esto no cambie en los próximos años [..] En
muchos otros, los cambios han sido limitados
y vacilantes, mientras que algunos países
que sí estaban muy avanzados en sus transiciones
de fecundidad han seguido caminos inesperados
con transiciones de fecundidad más lentas
o estancadas".
Bruno Schoumaker, demógrafo experto en África)
Ahí tenemos, por ejemplo, el caso de Egipto,
un país que parecia estar completando la
transición demográfica pero cuya tasa de
fertilidad ha pasado de 3 hijos en 2008 a
3,2 actualmente.
Un cambio en la tendencia que ha hecho que
la ONU incremente su población esperada para
el año 2050 hasta los 160 millones de habitantes.
Y de hecho aunque en el norte y en el sur
de África la transición demográfica está
muy avanzada, sus tasas de fertilidad se mantienen
muy por encima del resto del mundo.
Practicamente en niveles de más de 3 hijos
por mujer.
Sin embargo, lo que está ocurriendo en la
franja central del continente…
Eso es una auténtica explosión.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué demonios pasa en África?
Pues lo cierto es que no está claro.
Lo que se sabe es que la cultura, los gobiernos
y la religión son más pronatalidad que en
cualquier otra parte del mundo.
Sabemos que las encuestas nos dicen que en
general las familias africanas quieren tener
muchos hijos, que en general empiezan a tenerlos
muy pronto y que utilizan pocos anticonceptivos.
Por ejemplo en Níger las mujeres sueñan
con tener de 9 a 10 hijos, y los hombres 13.
En los 11 países con más crecimiento demográfico
del continente el primer nacimiento se suele
tener en la adolescencia.
Y en Angola, a pesar de que la mayoría de
la población vive en zonas urbanas y que
tiene un PIB per cápita relativamente alto,
la tasa de fencundidad sigue siendo de 6 hijos.
Pero vale, ahora que sabemos todo esto la
pregunta es: ¿Qué va a suponer exactamente
este cambio?
Pues….
Atentos.
(EL NUEVO AMANECER)
El mundo está cambiando tan rápido que es
posible que no seamos capaces de apreciarlo
en su plenitud.
Por ejemplo, ¿sabías que en 2020 por primera
vez las economías de Asia superaron en tamaño
a todas las del resto del mundo juntas?
Los países más ricos, y particularmente
los de la vieja Europa no solo se enfrentan
al estancamiento demográfico sino que, además,
tienen poblaciones cada vez más envejecidas.
Por ejemplo, se espera que para 2060 la población
de la Unión Europea apenas supere el 5% de
la población mundial.
Y no solo eso, el 30% de toda la población
europea tendrá más de 65 años.
En otras palabras que el mundo será cada
vez mucho más asiático, y sobre todo, mucho
más africano.
(“ Piensa en un continente que tendrá la
misma población que India y China juntas
en 2050.
Piensa en un continente con una clase media
creciente, una rápida urbanización y que
tendrá la población más joven del planeta
en 2050...
¡Piensa en África!".
Akinwumi Adesina, presidente del Banco Africano
de Desarrollo (BAfD))
La historia nos dice que poblaciones jóvenes
y crecientes han solido traducirse antes o
después en un creciente peso económico y
político.
Claro que esto también supone enormes retos.
Actualmente cada año 30 millones de africanos
alcanzan los 15 años, una edad que en esta
región se considera como el acceso a la vida
laboral.
Por eso durante los próximos años y las
próximas décadas África necesitará generar
enormes cantidades de empleo.
(Pero eso no es todo, además, aunque el continente
sea capaz de crecer, es evidente que su influencia
en el resto del mundo y el peso de la inmigración
va a crecer con fuerza.
Probablemente sobre todo en la vieja Euripa.
Al fin y al cabo es un continente próximo
que tendrá muchos empleos disponibles como
consecuencia del envejecimiento demográfico.
Así que, amigos, amigas, es muy posible que
para mediados de este siglo, África comience
a tener un peso mucho más destacado en la
agenda política, económica y comunicativa
del mundo.)
La pregunta es: ¿Estamos preparados?¿Será
una adaptación sencilla?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener para el resto
del mundo la emergencia de África?
¿Deben los países más ricos intentar promover
una cultura más abierta y moderna en África?
Hablo, por ejemplo, de la integración de
la mujer, el reconocimiento de la libertad
sexual o la integración de minorías de todo
tipo.
Queridoa amigos, amigas, estas son las grandes
preguntas que están por resolver.
Así que de moemento os invitamos a dejarnos
vuestras opiniones en los comentarios y abrir
debate.
Y por supuesto si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.